near the city of Milan on the island of
Java in Indonesia you will come upon a
massive structure in the misty
rainforests it's known as the garage I
am or as most people call it the chicken
church it's truly a foul sight
before we start I just want to give a
huge shout-out to writer Theodora Sara
Abigail who did some original reporting
and wrote an amazing piece on the
chicken church for Alice obscura it is
linked in the video description below
and was hugely influential in making
this video so thank you
rumors of this building have been on the
internet for a long time people thought
maybe it was some kind of crazy Dutch
colonialist building maybe it was some
kind of cult maybe it was haunted what
it actually is is the product of a dream
many of our best ideas come to us in our
dreams and in the case of Daniel alums
yeah it happened in 1988 after saying
his nightly prayers he received a vision
of a dove with snow-white wings
resting atop a hill a voice told him to
build a place of worship for all peoples
regardless of faith when we woke up he
was like yeah I'm not actually gonna do
that but the vision kept nagging at him
he couldn't stop thinking about it and a
couple of years later he went to visit a
co-worker who took him to this hilltop
Daniel watched the Sun Rise on Rhema
Hill and it happened as soon as Daniel
saw it he knew that this was the hill
from his dream and after a little more
praying daniel bought an acre of land on
the hill for 3.5 million rupiah or about
two thousand dollars keep in mind that
Daniel was not as crazy wandering mystic
or outsider artists he worked as a
project manager for a chemical company
it's not the background you might expect
for someone who went on to build a
prayer house after having a vision and
it wasn't simple either the first four
years were just consumed with the
paperwork of getting permissions to
actually build something like this but
in 1992 he was able to break ground and
got a 30-person crew together and he
started building his vision this huge
dove shaped building which would be open
to all kinds of people with all sorts of
different religious beliefs as you might
see by the iconography a dove a crown
Daniel's a Christian in a country that's
80% Muslim so people were a little bit
suspicious of this project and it shows
up in the name the chicken church is
this some kind of giant Christian cult
thing Daniel kept trying to tell
everyone it's not a chicken it's not a
church it's a place for all of us to
come together but in truth the
complaints were the least of Daniels
issues in 2000 he just ran out of money
he'd already built this enormous
structure the exterior was there but he
couldn't finish any of the interior he
had to leave you to basically abandon it
in the forest and over time it became
overgrown with vines and trees started
growing inside of it people came and did
graffiti and it really did start to feel
like the remnants of some crazy chicken
cult that someone had been running this
is where you come in and by you I mean
the internet 15 years later after Daniel
had had to step away and the chicken
church had been largely falling into
ruin it showed up on the Internet this
incredible strange abandoned space
pictures of it showed up on Huffington
Post they showed up on Alice obscura it
started to make the rounds and something
kind of incredible happened for a long
time you know a dozen people would show
up a week suddenly it went from a
trickle to a flood daniel was making as
much as $2,000 a week from the $1
tickets sold to the visitors and over
the last few years the chicken church
has undergone this incredible resurgence
and it's still improving he has turned
these empty concrete rooms into
beautiful mural covered spaces and today
you can not only climb through the
church and stand on the crown but you
get a free piece of fried cassava in the
cafe located in the butt of the chicken
church what a good deal that is the
chicken church has actually come back
it's come to be what he envisioned it is
literally in large part thanks to the
internet a dream come true thank you so
much for watching this video subscribe
to the channel to see other amazing
places all over the world and tell me
about what incredible dream project you
would build in the comments I have
always wanted to build some kind of
elaborate art installation behind a
waterfall but I'd love to hear what your
weird crazy dream project would be